the events of the past 24 hours have  been a serious  test for israel's new government you saw  militants in gaza launching incendiary  balloons these are basically  balloons that are on fire and aimed at  setting ablaze israeli farms close to  the gaza  border that was in response to a  rescheduled  march through jerusalem where there were  some clashes between palestinians and  police  leaving dozens injured  [Laughter]  i think both sides do have some  incentive not to escalate but of course  if another cycle of escalation spirals  out of control with both sides  trying to prove themselves it could be a  very  volatile and dangerous chapter  [Music]  [Applause]